okay so by now a lot of people have seen
the Dark Knight Rises and a lot of
people have seen my Dark Knight Rises
movie review and I thank you all for
watching my movie review and liking it
and surprisingly a lot of people were
like can you make a spoiler filled video
where you talk about the spoilers go
into a bit more detail and well my
initial movie review came out a few days
early and when you build my reviews
around no spoilers whatsoever it'd be
kind of [ __ ] me to be like okay
here's a review of arguably the most
anticipated movie of the summer full of
spoilers I couldn't really do that
without being a douchebag but since the
movies been out for a weekend now yeah
let's do a video with some spoilers so
if you haven't seen the Dark Knight
Rises yet don't watch this video unless
you really don't give a [ __ ] about
spoilers in which case hey welcome right
so one of the first statements of my
Dark Knight Rises review is that I was
surprised as to where the characters
were a Jim Gordon and Bruce Wayne of
course I was talking about Bruce Wayne's
look bit of a [ __ ] and he's a recluse
he's kind of crazy I thought that was
really awesome and the dude has no
cartilage in his legs he's physically
inferior to where he was he has a bunch
of sheets over his piano and furniture
and Wayne Manor it looks like he just
moved in Wayne Enterprises is in the
toilet I just I didn't expect him to go
that direction like Alfred told him you
hung up the cape and cowl but you never
moved on he never tried to be a person
you're so trying to be Batman with
nowhere to go which tells me one thing
which is even though the Joker is not
mentioned in this movie he has still
messed with people's minds eight years
later people are still messed up from
what the Joker did he blows away Rachel
Dawes he turns Harvey Dent into a
villain they have to cover up Harvey
Dent murders and they're all just still
messed in the head which also goes for
Jim Gordon I felt bad for that dude for
eight years he's had to smile in front
of the camera be like yeah Harvey Dent
truth and justice not oh yeah the guy
who tried to slaughter my kid the
douchebag the other thing I talked about
in my review is the unexpected direction
that the Dark Knight Rises takes and
that is of course the fact the bad guy
wins halfway through the movie you
really look at it he does although I
will always love the Joker most Bane
ultimately does what the Joker tried to
do in the Dark Knight Joker had his
victory with Harvey Dent but with Gotham
he said oh Gotham is my playground now
anyone who wants to stay here is gonna
play by my rules he tried to make Gotham
his own playground they were like all
Batman we must stop him Bane comes on
the scene he's like yeah I'll do that
halfway through my movie I thought that
was great it takes real balls for a
director and a storyteller to be like
alright I'm going to make the bad guy
win halfway through this movie you don't
really see that much you don't expect
that going to the
movie I was like all right yeah bein bad
guy Batman good guy of course I think
Batman's gonna lose the first fight he's
gonna have to work out come back and
stop him I don't know who's gonna be
like oh yeah Batman's gonna get his
nutsack kicked in and then he's going to
have to come back and take Gotham back
from the guy who has one that was
interesting that was awesome and it
brought this movie up a couple good pegs
that's why I loved Alfred in his movies
because he tells Bruce Wayne what we all
see he's like dude you just want to die
and you see that Bruce Wayne's like I
have nothing out there for me I just
want to die which was the thing that
bummed me out is that Alfred says peace
I'm out I'm not gonna bury a buried
enough members of the Wayne family and
after that you don't see Alfred until
the very very end of the movie in a
storytelling aspect I I understand why
Alfred wasn't in it I mean after Bruce
Wayne gets broken what's Alfred gonna do
he'd probably end up getting slaughtered
he's gonna be in Gotham it's not going
to show him that much anyway or he's
gonna be in Gotham and it's gonna show
him a lot and it's gonna be another
story arc that we have to cover in an
already long movie that's not long
enough to cover everything thoroughly
but I just would have liked to have seen
him more you can't deny that you know
you wanted to see more of Alfred even
though you understand why he wasn't in
it more and illustrate I thought Bane
was a complete badass there's that scene
where Batman and Catwoman are on the
roof fighting and they go over to the
edge and they're gonna jump onto that
bat I mean you know let the vehicle they
called the bat and Catwoman turns around
you see Bane just like walking towards
her like this and it has the bane music
it looks all like creepy
I was like that guys like Jason Voorhees
with a brain like he's always there he
never runs after you until he's there
and then after that he's going to be
moving lightning-fast punching pillars
and breaking them apart but the guy just
walks towards you in that creepy chance
happening you're like yeah blow hmm got
a run cuz I'm certainly not gonna fight
cuz I'm not an idiot if you're an idiot
he'll just be like a baroque or bein has
a few menacing moments like that once do
with that little Daggett weasel was all
like stay here I'm in charge Shane just
puts his hand on his children he's like
god I love that [ __ ] I was like I would
not feel in charge which is funny
because I saw a comment that said Bane's
voice sounds like Sean Connery's voice
talking through Optimus Prime's voice
box let's not stand on ceremony yeah mr.
Wain it kind of does you see where bangs
just going off but hey Sean Connery's
voice is badass which was also awesome
is in that whole montage where Bane's
just going off and you see rich people
getting dragged from their homes and
thrown into the street at first I
thought there were all the mercenary
guys but you look and there's like
bellhops and hotels are just hauling
rich people out into the street and
throwing him out there and I was like
holy [ __ ] the Joker was right the chips
are down and these civilized people are
eating each other doesn't matter they
didn't blow each other's ships up at the
end of the dark night no we're in it for
the long con that's another thing I
loved about Catwoman when Catelyn was
talking to Bruce Wayne and she's like
maybe I like it this way wishing stories
like this you see Catwoman is like that
in the end of course she ends up helping
him but initially she's like no I like
it this way even though deep down I kind
of don't I recognize his probably bad
and the scene I was talking about my
spoiler free review where I said that
there was a scene that I wish was about
a half an hour longer a situation that
was the scene after Batman gets his back
broken and he has to heal and crawl out
of that pit I mean he was in there for a
few months a few months it just didn't
feel like a few months I would have
liked to have seen more of the recovery
phase you know him becoming the Batman
again which like I said would take the
movie to be about a three and a half
hour movie but hey I'm willing to watch
it I want to watch it in fact I will
probably love it which is funny because
you know that chance that Rhys chance
you heard the trailers and in the
soundtrack it plays when Bane's on the
scene but in the end no one ever chanted
that for bane that was all Batman
they never crawled out of that pit they
never chanted for him they were chanting
for the Batman and you know when Bruce
Wayne's climbing out of that pit he
becomes the Batman again you know in
here you know you wanted to cheer for
him man that was badass and one of the
gripes about this movie is the way Bane
goes out and yeah he went out really
fast it was one hit that hit him but
it's not like he didn't get a fight
leading up to it it's not like Bane was
taking out mid-speech you know like the
cops and Bane's guys were all lined up
ready to fight and Bane stands up in his
alive girl he just takes one to the
chest and he's dead it wasn't like that
I mean we saw Batman fight Bane the
fight was over then the torch was passed
to another villain who's actually the
main villain and Bane's just their fact
that he got wasted doesn't change the
movie at all I couldn't see anything
else happening either Batman was gonna
get out of that situation and get away
and Bane wasn't gonna die or he was
gonna take a shot to the chest from
Catwoman on the Batpod and that would be
that which is funny because that Batpod
blows holes into concrete it blows away
cars pretty sure Bane gets shot in the
chest by that thing we'd pretty much
make him just it would just be a Bane
splat and that'd be that take it to a
hard-r but it would be so worth it and
of course the twist in the movie is that
Miranda Tate is actually Talia al Ghul
and I wish I didn't see anything on that
subject I mean months ago if you read my
blog I wrote on there all people have
seen her in this robe is she telle al
Ghul is she not and in the movie it said
that Bane is Ra's al Ghul son and at
that point I was like hmm okay well she
can't be Talia al Ghul cuz that would
make her and Bane brother and sister I
don't think he's gonna go there never
once thinking to myself well maybe Bane
isn't actually the child maybe it's
someone else like Talia al Ghul I just
went with it I didn't even think about
it and tell the scene where Batman threw
her the shotgun and he was like guard
the door then I was like wait a minute
total wardrobe change she's in a robe
now she wasn't a second ago she is Talia
al Ghul holy [ __ ] and if you look at it
what she's talking about her going green
project that they're gonna turn into a
bomb she talks about bringing balance to
the world and that's everything Ra's al
Ghul was talking about but I loved that
twist I love the fact that they just did
that so well the only bummer is for the
Bane Pyrrhus like I was talking about
who might think it's a little weird that
Bane is Ra's al Ghul's kid at a point
when it's revealed that she's Talia al
Ghul and Bane is not Ra's al Ghul's kids
that's really cool but you can't redo
the two hours you spent thinking that
Bane was
Ra's al Ghul's kid thinking that was
weird and I don't think everyone's going
to be like that but I think there are a
number of people who are like that
however when Gordon's in the back of
that big truck with the bomb and Talia
al Ghul is driving and it goes over that
thing and smashes and it kills her and
Gordon gets out of the back like oh
sweet I'm not a pizza right now I was
like you'd probably be dead and in this
whole movie you know that Batman's going
to probably die at the end and there's a
nuclear bomb that he has to fly out
there because the autopilots not on then
he flies out it blows up and you're like
Batman which in the end Batman gets his
name cleared because Bane brought out to
light he was all like oh crap but then
you find out that the autopilot was
fixed by Bruce Wayne now I've seen this
movie Twilight iams now I can't help but
I have a new friend that wants to watch
it I'm like okay I'll watch it with you
and it's better the second time and
better the third time but I was watching
for it I was like alright at what point
could he get out of the cockpit ejector
whatever but the editing in the movie it
shows him in that cockpit down for like
five seconds before it blows up so he
couldn't really get out but he does get
out because they say oh yeah he fixed
the autopilot which at first I was like
oh well maybe he fixed it but he wanted
to die anyway but then Alfred goes to
that one cafe he was telling Bruce Wayne
about and he sees Bruce Wayne there with
Selina Kyle people are saying oh is it
like Inception is it up to your own
interpretation I don't think so because
Alfred didn't know about Bruce Wayne and
Selina Kyle being you know a thing so I
don't see why Alfred would imagine
Selina Kyle there with him so now Bruce
Wayne is there with Selina Kyle because
he's nuke proof cuz even the cockroaches
got scorched by the fallout but not the
Batman
I like Bruce Wayne's funeral I like the
fact that the few people who knew that
Bruce Wayne was Batman they were there
and they got their closure they were
like yeah no one will ever know and but
there's a big statue in the middle of
town square alike and then and that's
cool know when Batman gave Jim Gordon a
clue as to who he was he was like give
me anybody it was someone who does
something as simple as put a goat around
a child and let him know the world
hadn't ended you think Gordon was like
oh yeah that one kid I ever did that
with cuz I never did to any other kid
because every other kid I was like coat
no no you know what I did that once
uh-huh who knows and of course we have
to touch on this and that is JGL as
Robin John Blake which is funny because
Christopher Nolan was like Robin will
never be in my movies and really he's
not this I think is open to a lot of
interpretation who says that John
Blake's real name is Robin that is a
throwback to the character Rob
he knows that Bruce Wayne is Batman then
he finds the Batcave and it ends there
so you're like yeah he's totally gonna
pick up the mantle and be the next
superhero but does that mean he's gonna
be Robin I don't necessarily think so I
mean a superhero whose superhero name is
the same as his own name that's like me
being a masked superhero named Jeremy
that's weird so is he gonna be Robin is
he going to be the next Batman because
Batman's assemble it could be anybody
all three movies illustrate this all the
time I don't know I kind of take the
Christopher Nolan trilogy as the actual
account of what happened in Gotham City
all the comic books and all that other
[ __ ] are the exaggerations of the truth
of what happened can't you see it like
Gotham City's a real place it actually
had things that happened and that is you
know what happened in the Christopher
Nolan trilogy then years later people
make comic books and like oh yeah Batman
and his sidekick Robin and some
historians alike I'm actually Robin
wasn't his psychic he was the one who
became Batman after Bruce Wayne but then
you know they just made comic books and
they figured oh well we'll just make
Robin his sidekick because they want to
sell toys I can kind of see it being a
realistic thing like that just kind of
how I said it and some people have
griped about that people like Robin
wasn't a cop well this is a new guy
named Robin whose future we don't really
know except the fact that he's going to
pick up the mantle in some way shape or
form is not saying he's Tim Drake it's
not saying he's Dick Grayson it's not
saying he's Jason Todd people ask me if
I see elements of Arkham City in this
movie I see elements of a few graphic
novels I see Arkham City nightfall a
little bit of Dark Knight Returns which
is my favorite graphic novel by the way
just Lenny now just like The Dark Knight
was kind of an homage to the long
Halloween I see this movie being in
homage to those in any case The Dark
Knight Rises is a great epic conclusion
to one of the best movie trilogies we
have I mean really you think about it I
mean there's Lord of the Rings and in
the Dark Knight trilogy you have your
light heart and stuff like Back to the
Future and the Indiana Jones movies
because there's only three of them
there's only three of them epic trilogy
is where all three parts are great
they're really hard to come by this is
one of the ones that succeeded now the
million dollar question to me is what do
I prefer the Avengers or The Dark Knight
Rises it'll sound like a cop-out but
ultimately they are two completely
separate movies with completely separate
tones and both do exactly what they're
supposed to do perfectly when the
Avengers is a great comic book movie
probably the best out there but the Dark
Knight Rises has concluded what the Dark
Knight trilogy did and that is transcend
past great comic book movie into
something bigger
something more and when a trilogy can
transcend past the box that started out
in dude you gotta give it props for that
it's got to be the Dark Knight Rises for
me who knows the conclusion of the
Avengers might be more epic but for now
Dark Knight Rises and I'm wondering how
many people out there think that means I
think the Avengers suck they both got
awesome tacular --zf rum me you can love
both we live in a world where you can
have both I'm just saying if there was a
gun to my head and I had to choose one I
would choose Dark Knight Rises so I'm
not going to ask you what you prefer the
Avengers of the Dark Knight Rises
because apples and oranges not going to
go there if you love both love both I'm
going to ask you what your favorite
trilogy of all time is there's enough
trilogies out there got to know what it
is what is it comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more